- So I'm asked one question most often.
Why didn't you sell your business?
It doesn't even make money.
By deleting images after you sent them,
we changed what it
meant to take a picture.
I think one of the perks of
being a really small company
is that from the beginning, we
got to think about diversity.
- He's an American internet entrepreneur.
He's the co-founder and CEO
of the mobile app, Snapchat.
He has an estimated net worth
of $2.1 billion dollars.
He's Evan Spiegel,
and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success.
Rule number five is my personal favorite
and I'm curious to figure out
which one you guys like the best.
As always, if Evan is saying something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put quotes around it so
others can be inspired as well.
(airplane flying)
- So I'm asked one question most often.
Why didn't you sell your business?
It doesn't even make money.
It's a fad.
You could be on a boat right now.
Everybody loves boats.
What is wrong with you?
(laughs)
And I'm now convinced that the fastest way
to figure out if you're doing something
that is truly important to you,
is to find someone who will
offer you a bunch of money
to part with it.
See the best thing is that
no matter whether or not
you sell, you will learn
something very valuable
about yourself.
If you sell, you will know immediately
that it wasn't the right dream anyways.
And if you don't sell, you're
probably on to something.
Maybe you have the beginning
of something meaningful.
- Do you worry about making the leap from
an inventor to a manager and
how are you handling that?
- Yeah, well I think that the solution
really is the team, right?
And so Bobby and I both have leaned
really heavily on some
really terrific people
that we've been able to hire
and frankly, I think that's
the only way to do it.
I think that the
challenging part from like
the learning perspective
is making commitments
that are that big at such a young age
to the people that work
for us and their families.
It's very hard for me to
use my phone to be honest.
I'm kind of like on text message and email
and our service so I'm
always yelling at our people
to try and, hopefully not yelling,
but trying to encouraging,
vigorously, vigorous encouragement,
to make this service more and more simple.
So every time we add a new feature,
we try to take a button away.
That sort of has spawned
a lot of our inventions,
like we have one camera
button on our service
and you can tap it to take a photo
but if you want to take a video,
you just press and hold.
And that in the past, if you remember,
still happens on a lot
of camera phones today,
you have to switch into video mode,
and you end up with all
these like weird videos
that you thought were pictures,
and pictures that you thought were videos,
doesn't really make sense.
So we're much more interested
in increasing engagement
rather than getting big.
So we really focus on a few markets
that are really important
to us and right now,
we're working on really
increasing engagement
and making sure that the
people that are on our service
just love it.
And that's what we watch
and I think over time,
we'll think about expanding the product
but right now, it's really
just a maniacal focus
on making great products
and deepening the engagement
with our service.
You already have inside of
you all of the amazing things
you need to follow the
dreams that you have.
And if you get stuck along
the way, there is a ton
of free information
available on the internet.
Have faith in yourself
and the person you're going to become.
Know that you are capable
of all of the growth
that will be expected of you
and that you expect from yourself.
You will tackle every
challenge headed your way
and if you don't, it won't
be for lack of trying.
Someone will always have
an opinion about you.
Whatever you do won't ever be enough
so find something important to you.
Find something that you love.
We really found something
special in Snapchat,
which at the time was called Picaboo,
and we found that by deleting
the images after you sent them
we changed what it
meant to take a picture.
So a picture wasn't about saving
a really important moment,
it was about communicating.
And we got really lucky
because smart phones
and their camera connected to the internet
meant that there really
was a big change happening
in communication that we
didn't totally identify
at the time but we do now,
which is that people prefer to communicate
with photos and videos rather than text.
Diversity for us is really
closely tied to competency.
So for us we have such a
diverse group of people
using our products and services everyday,
that in order for us to
make absolutely great
products and services for that community,
we need a really really
diverse group of people.
And it's really that simple.
So for us, we just have an
awareness that you know,
if we want to make the best products,
we need to have a diverse group.
- So can you describe your
diverse group of people,
I mean, what are some of the percentages
if you have them?
- Again, this is sort of the challenge
and I should have exact
percentages for you
but we just don't think about diversity
in terms of numbers that way.
And I think one of the perks
of being a really small company
is that from the beginning, we
got to think about diversity
so we didn't end up with a situation
where 10 years down the line,
oh my gosh I need to fix my numbers.
Because it's not really
cool to think about people
as numbers, right?
We think about people
and diverse skill sets
and so, for us, you know,
we're 300 people now
we were 30 people gosh,
a year and a half ago,
we've been really mindful that as we grow,
we need to hire diverse folks.
Conformity is so fascinating
and it's so pervasive
that it's been studied
for a very long time.
See it turns out, there are two things
that can dramatically reduce
conformity in a group setting.
The first is a single dissenting voice
and the second is the ability
to communicate privately
with other members of the group.
Our government gives
us the right to privacy
and the right to express ourselves freely
in the hope that we might
mitigate conformity.
Democracy wasn't designed
to promote popular thought.
It was architected to protect dissent.
For as President Kennedy said,
"Conformity is the jailer of freedom,
"and the enemy of growth."
- What circumstances were present
that made this idea catch fire?
- Sure, so I think there
were sort of two components
and the first component is probably
that social media was starting
to feel a little stale.
So there's only so many
beautiful, attractive, cool
pictures that you can take
and when you see all of them
day after day after day,
it just kind of gets boring.
So I think there was that aspect of it
and I think the other thing
is that we really identified
that this ephemeral thing
was core to conversation.
And so if you wanted
to have a conversation,
one of the best parts about it
was that you were left with the memory,
but not necessarily a transcript.
And I think that that really
drove the great feeling
that you have when you
share snaps with friends
and they're silly and not exactly perfect.
You know, there was obviously a place for
all of these great photos
that you wanted to save
and keep and there wasn't so much a place
to have a conversation.
And I think there's a
nice balance with both
and so I think we sort
of filled maybe a void,
the conversation void that was missing.
I'm obsessed with this
idea of no standard terms.
So when we were first getting started
and took financing, our
lawyers would take us through
the documents and they'd say,
oh don't worry about
it, it's all standard.
Then at the time I was
like, oh sure, standard,
that's great, no issues,
just standard, no problem.
And I've since learned that standard means
either the person who's walking
you through the documents
doesn't understand them or you could be
getting taken advantage of.
So when someone says something's standard,
just ask why and why and why and why
until you really understand intricately
how the deal is structured.
So I think that the big thing
that we took away from that
is standard terms is a huge red flag,
and beyond that just don't be afraid
to continue asking why.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Prasad Marne or Mar-neh,
I hope I got that okay, asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of the 10 rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
What change you're going to make?
What was the most touching
after watching this video?
What are you going to apply
to your life or your business?
Leave it down in the
comments and I will join
in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe or
whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon.
(airplane flying)